hey what's up guys mkbhd here back with
a quick video i know this isn't my usual
type or style of video but something is
really going around on youtube that i
want to get word out to you guys about
that's really bothering me uh there's a
scam or a very popular comment on some
of the most popular youtubers
pages like john four lakers or soldier
knows best or people who put out videos
that got a lot of comments that says to
go to gift before the word youtube and
just don't click on these links i'm
advising you now uh these this is a scam
quite obviously and it's a very alerting
scam because everyone wants a free gift
uh but the thing is i wanted to get this
out to you guys this video will probably
go down by the time uh this whole thing
settles down but i just want to warn you
guys because i really value you guys
as subscribers so don't click on those
links if you already have i'm assuming
this is something that they can use to
hijack or to get into your google
account which has a lot of valuable
information or your youtube account
which allows them to post comments from
your youtube account onto other people's
videos
so if you've clicked on this link
already i'd say to uh try try to change
your google password as that's the best
thing you can probably do
and if you haven't already good for you
do not click on these links
that's it i just wanted to get this
video out to you guys really quickly and
hopefully you guys are safe and sound
have a nice afternoon peace